le coronavirus fait vraiment chuter les
ventes de la bière corona aux états unis
depuis le début de l'épidémie des
consommateurs font à la blague
l'association entre le virus et la bière
bien un nombre incalculable de vidéos
amusantes et de parodies sur les réseaux
sociaux mais ça finit par rattraper
fabricant historique young ones et
samedi à l'image de la marque corona les
intentions d'achat de cette bière sont
maintenant un peu en deux en plus
d'avoir un nom qui ressemble à celui du
virus la corona est associée au voyage à
la plage on la crise freine la demande
pour ce type de déplacement un coroner
est habituellement la troisième hier la
plus populaire aux états unis selon
comscore lee chong wei l'accril du
coronavirus lui coûtera 170 millions
dollars américains en vente perdue pour
ses différents produits
[Musique]